overwhelmed hospitals people dying on
the streets from lack of oxygen
and packed crematoriums this is a
snapshot of the kevin 19 crisis in india
in contrast just a few months ago the
prime minister declared victory against
the
[Music]
after that there were political rallies
mass gatherings and religious festivals
like this one
and then on april 21st the country
reported a record number of covert 19
cases in a single day
and those numbers kept growing for
several weeks with many health experts
saying real numbers are likely much
higher
by may 7th death soared past four
thousand
as coveted cases in several western
countries have trended lower
the scale of infection in india and a
new variant first reported there have
alarmed the rest of the world
if you have a huge country like india
that's
that's deep in its own covet crisis
right that
that means the pandemic is not going to
end for the world
here's how india became the world's
coveted hotspot and what that means for
the global pandemic
first we have to go back to early 2020.
as much of the world was struggling to
contain the virus india appeared to have
things under
announced the world's largest lockdown
in the country of 1.3 billion people
he publicly came out multiple times and
said we have to pull together
we have to wear masks moved to socially
distance
there was a lot of respect for covid
restrictions and people were also
scared the measures triggered a mass
migration of workers trying to get back
home from cities
epidemiologists warned that this
movement of people could help spread the
virus
undetected to other parts of the country
but the number of reported coveted 19
cases remained relatively low
and india's apparent success stood in
contrast to some other countries
including the us which was reporting
more cases than any other nation
some public health experts said a
possible reason for few cases in india
could have been the lack of widespread
testing
but they also noted that the majority of
the population is under 25
and since asymptomatic cases are more
common among young people
many may have gone undetected after a
10-week lockdown
india started to ease restrictions and
the number of cases started growing with
the first peak in september
it was quite bad and the healthcare
system was
stressed but the hospitals didn't you
know crumble or
buckle and we saw that um actually in
other parts of the world it was much
worse
despite that first surge by december
india's numbers had gone back down
and by early 2021 life looked like it
was returning to normal
stores were back open they were super
packed restaurants were open
filled with people indoor dining there
were cricket matches
again packed stadiums life in
delhi felt like another universe the us
was dealing with another wave
right in december january india was
doing very well compared to the us or
the uk
and that's when modi touted the
country's success in front of other
global leaders at the world economic
forum
so what went wrong public health experts
blame india's ferocious surge on a
combination of new factors
the first one people became more relaxed
about coveted safety measures
many people stopped wearing masks and
there were several crowded gatherings
which public health experts say may have
been super spreader events including
huge political rallies
april was a key election month and
political parties including modi's bjp
party organized events across the west
bengal state
a bjp spokesperson said that no one had
anticipated the magnitude of the covet
19 surge
adding that modi and other members of
his party followed all the safety
protocols in place at the time
right around then resources to fight the
pandemic weren't reinforced or
maintained
everyone essentially thought that covid
was over
by january hospitals were taking down
their coven 19 wards
testing centers that had been
started last year were also being
dismantled some of the auction
plans where they had allocated the
budget were never built
and on top of all of this highly
contagious variants that were first
identified in the uk and south africa
were circulating in the country
as well as a new variant known as b1617
that originated in india the 617 in
india
it's a wily opponent the who has said
preliminary studies indicate that this
one may be more contagious than some
other variants
and has since been detected in more than
40 countries
including the us uk and france
this has added urgency to the global
vaccination race
which has so far helped cases plummet in
some of those countries
so even as the coveted situation has
improved in some parts of the west
the fight against the pandemic across
the globe is far from over
a big lesson is just countries can't get
complacent
and even if one country is doing well if
another country
is not doing well in terms of covet that
will affect every other country
in the world too